you're gonna hear a number of
collaborators and partners and we're
gonna start with my friend rich
Fitzgerald I'll give a very quick
introduction first and foremost he's a
CMU alum
hmm has a degree in mechanical
engineering from our College of
Engineering in in the early 80s rich has
served as the Allegheny County serves as
Allegheny County Executive as you know
his leadership touches so many aspect of
our campus lives academic mission and
the entire community and we're so
delighted to count him as an alum as a
trusted friend and and one of our
wonderful leaders in this town please
join me in extending a warm welcome to
rich Fitzgerald rich thank you foreign
demand thank you for your great
leadership and I do not have a
PowerPoint so I won't have it the out of
order we do that all the time so I just
I'm glad to see that this great
University we all those things happen
and as I look over to my left and I see
the two Dean's and and we talk about
which one's more important civil
engineering or mechanical engineering it
reminds me of when I go to fish fries
which one do you like the best I'm not
going to answer that question we just we
don't go there
this is great and congratulations to all
of you how a metro 21 and traffic 21
that birth that a number of years ago
and smart cities and where we're going
as a community Pittsburgh seems to get
these accolades all the time and there's
actually one this morning if you saw in
your morning paper that Money Magazine
named Pittsburgh the best place to live
in the Northeast best city to live in
the Northeast
[Applause]
and and and what Farnum talked about was
I think why that is it's the partnership
and the collaboration and all of us
working together to make it a better
place and we know how mobility and
traffic and and all the things that you
know we live with on the day to day
basis are a big part of that and as the
county executive we we only have two
little things under traffic that matter
to us your transit system and your
Airport just two little minor things
that affect us so but but I can tell you
that the great work that this university
has done for us has really improved both
of those particularly the airport you
know our airport was really in a bad
state a number of years ago and now it's
it's on the move in in more ways and we
can we can imagine Airport of the Year
getting more flights getting more
connections getting better service more
frequent service all those type of
things you're gonna have Kathryn
Kellerman here this afternoon the Port
Authority director and where she just
started a little over a month ago and we
want to move that agency almost in the
very same direction you know to make
improve people's lives in a better way
working with Corina Rick's you're gonna
hear from next the city's mobility and
infrastructure director and and and that
great work that they're doing together
is is tremendous and then and then how
do we not only do those things but make
sure that the environment in which we're
living in is better as well how do we
improve air quality because we know the
amount of fossil fuels that are burned
in moving our vehicles back and forth
and you know as we sit in traffic and
congestion how do we how do we use that
how do we make that better and we know
what you've done already in some of the
traffic signaling in East Liberty and
through the East End corridor has
improved and how do we continue to build
upon that by the partnerships that we
have so I'm very excited and optimistic
about where we're going I'm excited
about the Amazon stuff so anybody in the
press here that's gonna get any of the
secrets I ain't giving them but but I
think we something we should all be
proud of and this institution should be
extremely proud of it because its front
and center of why we made that top 20
and why we're we're growing again in a
great
we want to make sure we grow in a
sustainable way some of those numbers
that Farnum talked about the the folks
that are moving to and growing in urban
areas as cities continue to grow I hear
that all the time for my County
colleagues around the state who are
talking about how their young people are
leaving and moving to move into the
cities move into places like Pittsburgh
and Philadelphia and how do we deal with
that how do we make sure that that
happens so we're delighted to
participate we're here with a lot of our
folks from economic development from
from transportation from infrastructure
from Public Works and all the things as
we continue to partner with that are
that are making this work
the one thing am i introducing karina
has she are you coming back up you're
doing that okay because I was going to
give her a little I mean you know Carina
Rick Susan who's come here and done some
great work and CMU and all the the data
that they have working on I think one
piece of day that they weren't sure is
how do we make the road better when the
hillside above it slides down onto it
that's probably data that we weren't
anticipating but those are the things in
Pittsburgh with it with the climate we
have in the world that we live in that
we're also going to have to make sure we
consider as well as we build and what do
we do with all those all those factors
that affect that so we're glad to be
here thank you for enough for putting
this together your great institution and
the team that you have is making
Pittsburgh a better and better place
thank you
[Applause]